i used to struggle reading the quran
daily before you instructed instructed
me to download this app i never knew
that this app would have such an impact
on people's lives you can go into the
description box click the link for ios
and android and build your habit with
the quran right now assalamu alaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends i
came across this video which i found
disturbing this is
an australian i think it's australian
revert to islam i don't know when you
come to it's time you get a bit zealous
you get a bit overexcited you know it's
the truth you've been lost we understand
that but it gives you no right to do
this number one morally number two islam
forbids you allah says in the quran
actually before we go to that let's
watch the video let's watch the video
first
okay
and there you guys you go guys you saw
it for yourself she's smashing this idol
of an elephant and saying you know look
we understand your frustration like you
know he was worshiping his something
that's handmade it's if you think about
logically it's it's crazy i mean imagine
making something with your own hand and
saying this is god and you're giving it
food and it can't even help itself you
know it is pathetic let's be honest we
can intellectually academically um
convey that you know to the opposing
parties you know uh hindus but that
doesn't give you a right to smash their
idols this is forbidden allah tells us
that we are not even allowed to insult
their gods verbally let alone physically
now you'll be thinking hold on a second
ali why what i'm saying what about the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him what
about ibrahim yeah okay these are
specific incidents these are exceptions
to the rule why because now for example
if we argument say there's a nation that
is idle worshipers okay and islam goes
to conquer those lands and when they
conquer those lands
they have a right if they are the ruling
party now to get rid of those idols they
have they have a right to they have a
right to get rid of the idols this
doesn't mean on an individual level you
go out and provoke people and smash in
their idols you don't do that you know
because you get the sin you know if you
insult their gods and they insult back
which allah says in the quran that you
know they are going to say something
without knowing and you provoke them you
will get the sin it's like insulting
islam we have a principle but if you
insult somebody's mother and they taught
your mother you get the sin you get the
sinful insults in the mum and you get
the same for them insulting your mother
because you caused it
it is not allowed in islam for us to
behave in this way of smashing breaking
things even when islam conquered lands
there were group of people
for example this might go for adult
kitab you know the people of the
christians of the jews they had their
monasteries they had the synagogues they
had their place of worship they have
their crosses you know they can walk
around their crosses etc islam gives us
rights we are not allowed to go and do
this kind of stuff and even if we look
at for example egypt when it was
conquered by muslims they didn't touch
certain architecture you know statutes
etc even though i don't think they
worship them but for some reason the
muslims let them be we don't know why
but the point is this this attitude is
wrong it's disgraceful and as a muslim i
have to tell you that is unacceptable
and childish and immature behavior it's
as simple as that but you should repent
from okay we understand your frustration
you can verbally say it i used to
worship this tell us your story that'd
be more powerful than you getting in and
going on a hype thing that's what i have
to say bro and sisters until next time
assalamu alaikum
may allah make us among those not only
have knowledge but have wisdom to apply
that knowledge
goodbye